right welcome everyone to this meeting
of the um Council
I'm counselor James Caston chairman of
mid-suffolk District Council and I'll be
chairing the meeting today I'd like to
begin this meeting with a minute silence
for Queen Elizabeth II we haven't had a
meeting since um we lost our um
wonderful Queen and if everyone would
just like to um take a moment to just
remember her please
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the Ipswich Town Football
Club training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to silent and
laptops please turn to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
on the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to this
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you have
also consented to being filmed by the
council and to possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council mem the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
before this meeting commences I'd like
to welcome if the alley
to the meeting as the new interim
director for Law and governance and the
monitoring officer
and I'd also like to take this
opportunity to welcome councilor Pratt
back from and congratulate him on the
birth of his son Lars and talking from
experience I'm I'm already getting my
eight hours a week sleep
so it's not too much of a problem
I'll move to the agenda apologies for
absence
thank you chair obviously apologies
throughout
for our counselor Davies and councilor
Phillips
thank you very much and item two is
Declarations of Interest by councilors
so um all the councilors have been
granted dispensations from the
monitoring officer to discuss the
independent remuneration report which is
item 19 members who are on Boards of the
council's companies have also been
granted dispensations from the
monitoring officer with regards to item
11 on the agenda are there any other
Declarations of Interest
no
so item three is to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 21st of July
2022 for accuracy only are there any
issues with accuracy
now could I have a proposal for the
minutes please
counselor
geek sorry sorry counselor gee apologies
it's that eight hours a week sleep
um anchored over second her please
councilor Richardson thank you all in
favor can we do that by show of hands
please
I think that's carried yeah that's
carried
Chairman's announcements I'll refer you
to paper
mc2218 for noting I did attend a reef
Lane event in Stone Market
um the day after the um the queen sadly
died which isn't included
um I also held a Chairman's event at
burnt House Vineyard
um which um thank you for all of you
that attended
um it was very it was very successful
and I'm really pleased with how it went
thank you so um item five the leaders
announcements I'd like to invite
councilor Morley to present her update
any questions for the leader
um can be emailed but I will be taking
questions of clarity only on on her
report afterwards so councilor Morley
thank you
thank you chair
I know it has been several weeks since
Queen Elizabeth's death and the queen
and the King's Proclamation
political and economic events have
dominated our news Cycles over the last
month but I wanted to take this
opportunity to respectfully Mark the
death of our late Queen at full Council
and the proclamation of the king
God Save the King
turning back to politics I'm sure all of
us will want to congratulate prime
minister Rishi sunak we wish him well as
he has a huge task ahead of him
local government and in particular
mid-suffolk
stands ready to support government with
its priorities
but I will also take this opportunity to
remind Westminster that local government
and in particular mid-suffolk is the
most efficient and Innovative part of
the public sector
trust us back us and wherever possible
provide greater Financial certainty to
the sector and devolve more powers to
local government
despite the period of national mourning
it has been an extremely busy period
since we last met
this has included
further curiosity events with HSBC
and the NHS
helping to raise the aspirations of our
young people and make them more aware of
the opportunities that exist Within
mid-suffolk
also helping children and families
to stay happy healthy and active during
the holidays through Outdoor Adventure
days football dance camps swimming and
family cooking sessions
our fabulous Innovation Awards
congratulations again to all the local
businesses who are shortlisted for these
Awards
and I want to take this opportunity to
remind all of our businesses that they
are still able to access free digital
workshops as part of our digital skills
program before November
our businesses are also able to apply to
participate in our new program
jointly funded with the University of
Essex to help them take the next steps
towards Innovation and growth
the purchase of mid the purchase by
mid-suffolk that has enabled the
expansion of the John peel Center into
11 Marketplace in Stone Market
and the John pearl center also hosted
our very well attended what's next for
Stow Market event during September and
The Stone Market health education and
Leisure facilities scheme survey which
some of you may know better as the Shelf
project closed last week and I'm really
looking forward to seeing the outcome of
that survey soon
it was also fantastic to see our
building control team successfully
winning a regional award in the annual
local Authority building Control
building excellence awards
the Regal in Stone Market won the best
non-residential extension or alteration
and we will now move on to the fight
National Final in London in January 2023
granting planning permission to the
first site at Gateway 14 with a new
facility owned by the range will create
1 650 new jobs
in Holston we have funded the creation
of a wonderful Wildflower Jubilee Meadow
that together with our district-wide
tree canopy survey work
and Wildflower verges trials are all
helping to tackle biodiversity and
climate change
and most importantly continuing to help
tackle the cost of living crisis for our
residents
we are currently Consulting about
increasing the level of to council tax
discount to 100 percent
and through Suffolk public sector
leaders we have agreed to fund a new
fuel poverty retrofit team designed to
deliver 50 million pounds worth of
retrofit works
such as insulation fitting air source
heat pumps and replacing single glazing
this is alongside solar together Suffolk
which is a separate group buying scheme
which has already helped over 1 500
homes in Suffolk to install solar panels
and batteries and opened for new
registrations from August this year
through Suffolk waste partnership we
have launched a new campaign to help
families reduce food waste and save
money
and finally I want to encourage all her
community groups and non-profit
organizations to apply for our winter
warmth support Grant which closes next
week
this grant is open for applications from
250 pounds up to 5 000 pounds to cover
the cost the rising costs of energy rent
and food and to keep operating without
passing on increased
cost to our residents
thank you chair
good morning
councilman can I have a question on
clarification chair yes of course um
yeah the you mentioned the um harleston
um Meadow it was it was created by the
and funded by the local community and
the district council kindly provided
some seed
um Wildflower seed which is very good
but um it wouldn't be reasonable to say
that the council had actually created it
because the local community did that
okay thank you
item six on the agenda is um
notification notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
procedure rules
item seven questions by the public in
accordance with the council procedure
rules
item eight
quiz by council's in accord in
accordance with the council procedure
rules I refer you to the questions in
the table papers Council counselors
please remember that supplementary
questions should not be preceded by a
statement and must relate to the
original questions the I'd like to now
invite councilor Mansell to ask her
question
uh thank you chair
um I I asked this question I submitted
my question before there was a press
release earlier this week which may uh
to some extent answer my question but
I'm still going to ask it because I then
can have a supplementary question
um so my question is is the council
offering help and support to Village
Halls parish councils and other
community groups to facilitate social
gathering in heated communal spaces
during this period of soaring Energy
prices and as winter approaches thank
you
platman
my thumbs are a little bit there but
I'll you know persevere uh the term warm
Banks has emerged in recent months and
is encouraging Community locations this
winter to remain open for longer to
provide people with a warm safe place to
be rather than heating homes or living
in a cold property
the council has launched its winter warm
support front and is available to
support small Grassroots Community
groups and other not-for-profit
organizations that support residents
across mid-suffolk with the cost of
living crisis by offering one-off grants
to support the anticipated increases in
running costs between November 2022 and
April 2023 including rent increases and
electricity costs Rises this will enable
Community groups to open more often
during this period and for longer to
support local residents by providing a
warm place to be
as the leader said grants off between
two feet 250 and up to 5000 can be
applied for and the deadline for the
application is 5 PM on the 31st of
October the link to the grant is on our
communities web pages warm warm winter
warm
support Grant baby Suffolk thank you
uh yeah thank you chair and thank you
for your response Council flatmund uh
now we only got notified of of this
scheme for the community grants earlier
this week I think it was about six days
ago and applications have to be in by
Monday that's quite a short time limit
so is are there any plans for any any
future
um widening of the support Grant
application window and any long-term
support
however
um we have had a lot of application
running already so people are on it I
emailed all my parishes the moment I
knew it was going out and I think you'll
find that that will be probably up to
the limit of what we're offering but we
will see and it depends on the level of
us from groups we are hoping to attract
many smaller Community groups to reach
across the district many of these groups
only need small amounts of money to
support or extend their work with our
residents so we could support higher
numbers Maybe
that's the field to ask his question
I'm pleased to see that sifco have a
successful year and at the time their
report was produced had recovered the
property value that existed
and I've lost my screen just a minute
uh
we covered the property value that had
existed at the time of the various
purchases however that was some time ago
and there's been considerable Financial
turbulence NASA and internationally
since the accounts were drawn out could
the cabinet member give us a view of the
likely impact of dramatically Rising
interest rate on the district council's
program to finance The Cisco investment
and a likely recession
unlikely effective recession would have
on the city Core Business
would also there be sufficient detail
for members of the public and councilors
to understand the risks involved it
would appear that cifco companies will
be in some problems with the recession
and property values very valuable fall
substantially
that's the field I'd like to invite
councilor Gould to answer
thank you very much uh chairman and uh
thank you uh councilor Ford for your uh
for your very personal question uh I'll
start by saying I I share your pleasure
about sifco's continuing continuing
success I saw two parts to your question
one is really about the um
borrowing rates
and a dramatically Rising interest rates
as you put it and the second was as I
said about the resilience of the
portfolio and the Investments we had if
I do this that second one first if I if
I may
um the uh
sifco portfolio remains strong uh
despite all the volatility about uh
around the economy that we've had and
also a phrase given to me the
geopolitical environment
um now the key things that actually uh
demonstrate the resilience of the
portfolio is that the the weighted
average lease contract is at 6.4 years
across 78 tenants providing uh sifco
with a diversified and resilient income
stream and of course it is that income
stream that is the main purpose of sifco
the projected revenue for 23 24 remains
in line with the current year despite uh
the predicted recessionary headwinds
uh further diversification and
diversification of the portfolios again
one of the characteristics are of its
strength uh and resilience that
um we've got 21 properties in the
portfolio as you know across different
uh property sectors uh one of the core
markets that we're in we have 55 waiting
for portfolio in the industrial sector
uh and that remains is a very strong
sector with low development and vacancy
levels and there's a strong demand
um our portfolio is substantially LED
with a very low void rate of 2.9 percent
and the revenue collection of rents
remains above 98 uh percent at this
point with only 0.01 attributable to uh
pre-pandemic uh arrears
so while Capital values uh are subject
to volatility and values have adjusted
to the rising cost of debt the core
fundamentals of generating a sustainable
and robust Revenue stream from the
councils remain and that is the core
objective of sifco now in terms of the
part of your question match uh interest
rates the council is monitoring the cost
of debt of debt situation very closely
as you would expect the exposure to
fluctuations in short-term interest
rates is minimal at the moment as this
Council took advantage of some low rates
with other local authorities before
those rates increased the council also
has maybe in contrast to another Council
some longer term borrowing at fixed
rates
so the council's in a position reviewing
the impact for next year as part of the
budget preparation and we will be
presenting uh revised projections in the
budget for 23 24. uh I'm notwithstanding
your your absolute right to raise a
supplementary question of course we have
a substantive report on this agenda uh
the sipco business plan the substantive
and indeed substantial report on this
agenda uh
looking forward the business plan for
the coming year and we've also have an
impressive array of zip code directors
and advisors who can help with masses
when we get to that substantive item
thank you very much
[Music]
good question
thank you thank you for your answer
returning to the interest issue
um the council has considerable
borrowings as you say many of them long
term
but I do notice from the financial
analysis that we have some 30 million of
short-term loans at
.02 sorry 0.2 percent which is a weight
you might have some difficulty achieving
today and really what I was looking for
was an indication of the impact of that
in its totality perhaps on the council
because the numbers we have don't quite
allow me to separate the long and
short-term debts between the council's
core activities and allows for funding
Swift area or Gateway 40 in for that
matter both of which have very
substantial borrowings thank you
Council called
as a I anticipated the the end of answer
your your principal question there uh
if you can
um
pose that question of the 151 officer uh
and uh particularly the 151 officer I
think when we get to the substantive
item I think you're getting more
comprehensive uh uh answer then I would
be able to give you at this moment
thank you very much
all right councilor Mellon to ask a
question
this question is for
news for housing many of the refugees
from Ukraine who came to Suffolk
under the homes for Ukraine scheme are
coming to the end of their first six
months of guests as guests here and and
are needing to find new accommodation
and where do these vulnerable people
stand in terms of qualifying for social
housing
thank you councilman councilor Haddon
thank you
thank you for your question as a local
Council we are not responsible for
arranging alternative accommodation
should home speak Ukraine sponsors
decide not to continue as host Beyond
six months under the skiing hosts should
work with their guests to find
alternative accommodation either with
friends or family who could host and sit
instead or helping them to find private
rented Solutions if they can afford to
do so it is only if they're able to find
unable to find alternative at their hang
on it is only if they're unable to find
an alternative and are therefore in
danger of becoming homeless that we
would step in
Ukrainian refugees under the homes for
Ukraine Visa scheme are eligible to join
the housing register in both baber and
mid-suffolk district councils and their
housing needs will be assessed in line
with the current allocations policy once
they've been assessed they are able to
bid bid for properties however this
could take some time to their successful
and they will need to widen their area
choice to be housed rehoused into social
housing and this will be dependent where
they're looking to live and the size of
accommodation required information has
been provided to support Ukrainian
refugees and how to apply for social
housing on our website
gateway2homechoice.org.uk there's also
information on waiting times based on
area that can be used to give an
indication on how long it is likely to
be rehoused and that is on our website
gatewaytonechoice.org dot UK property
search index
thank you councilman do you have a
supplementary question I do
um
given the huge amount of uncertainty for
host families and their guests
are we doing
what we promise to do at the start of
the crisis which is to wrap support
around our Ukrainian guests and their
host families thank you Council
man
um I can I can give you a um sorry
um I can I can just tell you that how
many cases we've dealt with that is that
helpful
so we've had um um
in terms of cases so far would be nice
to step in it's only been a handful
compared to the total number within our
districts out to 14 cases nine in
mid-suffolk and five in baber six have
been resolved having been offered advice
one has been rehoused in the private
rented sector two have been rematched
rematched with new host families three
cases have been closed as applicants
have either left the UK or approached
other authorities and we have two cases
remaining where we continue to work with
the families to prevent them becoming
homeless
if that helps thank you very much I'd
like to go back to council Mellon do you
have a question for councilor Whitehead
uh for councilor Whitehead with
businesses moving into the Freeport or
the investment Zone not quite sure if
that's still happening uh but they're
not paying business rates there'll be a
loss of income into the council coffers
is the the portfolio holder confident
that central government will make up
this short form
thank you for your question councilor
Mellon um the short answer is yes but in
terms of more detail the Freeport
investment zones as with the preceding
Enterprise zones have a program of
support for businesses locating on site
including business rates up to 100 of
rates payable for five years for three
port and 10 years for investment zones
that's where other forms of started to
release any discount to businesses
locating on these sites will be paid to
the council by central government via a
section 31 Grant this ensures that
discounts to businesses do not come at a
cost to the local Authority
councils hosting freeports or investment
zones will receive 100 of the business
rate growth in designated sites above an
agreed Baseline for 25 years
do you have a supplementary question I
do thank you
um can I ask has any assessment been
made of the impact of the disparity of
tax regimes inside and outside the
Freeport or investment zones and
particularly the impacts on communities
if businesses decide to move from
outside to inside thank you thank you
councilor Whitehead
um that's probably a question better um
directed at Jeremy Hunt I think because
it's a nationwide thing but certainly we
ourselves haven't done any studies that
I'm aware of
um now I'd like to invite councilor Eben
to ask her questions
that's to councilor Whitehead
um thank you very much chair
um for the financial year
2021-22 an additional 4 million pounds
was available on top of the normal
budget to be spent on separate projects
another 1.1 million was added to this
for the financial year 2022-23
of this total 5.1 million extra funding
how much has actually been spent to date
thank you
thank you for your question councilor
Reuben I think you're quite right to ask
for an update on these major spending
programs it feels so much surreal
actually standing here to reporting on
additional spending of 5.1 million when
I'm sure many other councils up and down
the country at this time wrestling with
the challenges of finding spending cuts
running into millions of pounds and
would relish being in our big Civic
situation but our offices and staff have
been busy working on about 50 individual
projects within its ambitious program to
support our residents and communities
while we have spent approximately 1.5
million to date a majority of the rest
of that money has been committed to
projects that are being rolled out in
several phases
been spent on fixed term stuff posts
that's still the majority of their time
to run
and to funds that can be drawn down as
needs demands for example support
Victors of domestic abuse or grants to
support Energy Efficiency in the private
rental sector or support businesses
through various schemes where
applications can be made
they'll also use additional money to
lever insignificant additional match
funding from external organizations
which is in the region of four hundred
thousand to date which is close to 438
000 Target that we set our offices
the cabinet however would like all
members to have a more detailed update
of all the work that we have in progress
until that end we've asked officers to
provide us with an all member briefing
on this before Christmas
do you have a supplementary question I
do chair and I'm a bit
um since I'm not that since um councilor
Whitehead is able to make statements
before he answers I'm still a bit
concerned we can't then make statements
but there we are
um yes thank you very much for your
comprehensive response and I look
forward to a briefing on that
um the if only 1.5 million of that's
been spent to date
you know that is a is a good you know
since we allocated that four million
that's a good 18 months on from that and
if could you give me assurances that of
the remainder so that's 3.6 million will
be spent by the end of the financial
year and if it isn't can we please then
use it to address the cost of living
crisis such as by providing a council
tax rebate for those citizens that most
need it while there's a cost of living
crisis thinking
he then counts the Whitehead thank you
I'm not sure as much as statement is
trying to put it into context but um in
terms of your question the some of these
projects are designed to run over a
couple of years they've taken some time
in terms of recruitment to get traction
I would accept but basically a project
that lasts for two years will not be all
spent by the end of this year but the
spending and commitment is different but
we shall see by the end of the year well
as part of this all member breathing
we'll look at what's spent what's
committed and what is spare which I
suspect we're very little thinking
thank you and I'd like to now invite
councilor Stringer to ask a question of
counselor burn
chairman uh councilor burn does the
portfolio holder for planning agree that
mid Suffolk should develop its own local
policy guidance for determining solar
farm applications
thank you councilor Byrne
as you are I'm sure aware there is a
policy on energy sources storage and
distribution within the emerging joint
local plan that's policy LP 25.
now that local plan is still under
examination
I'd already asked officers to look into
how we might supplement this
and my suggestion is that we will
develop and adopt a renewable energy and
low carbon position statement
so that we can move quickly whilst
recognizing that this is a complicated
matter
as I say this is by no means a simple
issue with energy security food
production landscape impacts and
Heritage to enable to feel the
considerations our officers and members
of planning committees must grapple with
we have raised our concerns and
frustrations about the lack of joined up
thinking of energy related projects
versus food production at the national
level
and have encouraged animals to teach
joined up national plan for energy
development to be drawn up
however we will continue to work towards
doing what we can at a local level to
provide guidance on our new joint local
Planet policies through the position
statement that I referred to earlier
thank you very much councilor would you
like to make yeah
I think the answer was yes
I'm sorry I could have said that very
quickly instead of reading all that out
yes cool yeah yeah right that's fine
okay so the that's not my supplementary
by the way that was my original question
just testing just testing uh yeah so if
the answer is yes if the answer is yes
why have we not introduced this to date
and when will this guidance be ready
the first part of it was why haven't we
introduced it to date
uh and when will it be ready
I still didn't catch what the first few
words of that
the two phrases okay
why haven't we introduced this guidance
to date
and now that we're going to get it when
will it be ready
right
um we haven't introduced it today
because the the situation has been very
fluid
um it is being worked on at the moment
and hopefully it will be ready
um in the early part of next year and by
that I mean round about
February March time but if you would
like a a more complete answer because
um I haven't got all the details at my
fingertips I'll ask um uh our corporate
manager for planning policy to give you
a fuller a fuller answer if I may
be done through email or other channels
thank you very much
um and um thank you everyone that
concludes the questions some item on the
agenda I'd like to move to item nine
which is mc2219 overview and scrutiny
committee report and I'd like to invite
councilor Wellen to introduce the report
thank you chair my report starts on page
19 uh of your papers I just like to
highlight a couple of things
um the cefco performance and Pacifica
business plan was scrutinized back in
June seems a long time ago and we'll be
looked at again next year
you'll note that joint overview and
security agree to recommend to council
that overview and scrutiny continue to
scrutinize cifco performance and
business plan and continue to make a
report back to full Council which should
be taken into account when the portfolio
holder reports to council
uh the comments of the committee are
included in the minutes
of the of the joint of the security
committee meeting and they're attached
as appendix F to the council report
joint overview scrutiny committee
scrutinize The Joint parking strategy
but unfortunately this was after the
cabinet report on the strategy had been
made public a few days before the
cabinet meeting it would have been
better to have had the opportunity to do
so earlier so that our comments could
have been taken into account in the
report which was being made to cabinet
a number of concerns were raised about
mainly about the data that had been
collected and they are set out in my
report and in the minutes of that
meeting
a joint overview security also
recommended I was to recommend on
options for a council tax reduction
scheme and set out in my report as is
the option that we recommended and the
reasons for making that recommendation
in summary the recommended option would
ensure no household would be worse off
as a result of introducing the scheme
and households with the lowest incomes
would pay no council tax at all
the task and Finnish group for Rural
transport has finally made
recommendations
and suggests that these are taken into
account as work proceeds on the electric
bus project
you share happy to answer questions
account for eBay
thank you very much chair and thank you
councilor welcome for your report
regarding the rural transport task and
finish group that's on page 23 paragraph
3.2.4
will the local consultation into unmet
transport needs also cover input from
Suffolk County Council regarding
cancellations to bus services and where
people who used to have use a scheduled
bus that now they can't because it
doesn't run or the timetables changed
and therefore use taxis instead whether
sharing with neighbors or on their own
thank you
councilor wellum
thank you Council reburn um yeah I mean
the main drift was intended to be
judging unmet Demand on the number of
refusals that connecting communities
have to make
um they cannot meet every every need so
they turn down some some requests
because they don't have a vehicle they
don't have a driver available so that
was going to be the main Drift But also
there would be local consultations once
uh once an area is is considered as to
be a suitable for introducing a project
then there would be more formal
consultation with residents and I think
one of the things that we would need to
pick up on is the people who used to go
on the bus
just to have a ride just to go to visit
somebody or to visit a place and now
they don't go out at all but but also we
need to pick up on those people who
don't use them can't use the bus because
there is no bus but they club together
to use a taxi so yes there is unmet
demand there are a number of different
types of unmet demand that we need to to
pick up on thank you
councilor Manson
thank you chair and thank you councilor
well and for your report I I welcome the
resolution
um that you got on the um discussion
about the parking strategy that the that
you've requested the cabinet to look
into other areas and and report back but
I'm just a bit concerned that there's no
time scale on this resolution so I
wondered if there was a time scale
um you know in mind but it's not
actually in the bold print thank you
Council weather
thank you chair thank you councilman so
um we did not set a time scale it was
possibly an error that we didn't set at
a time scale but I'm sure we will be
able to speak with the leader and cab
and Cabinet member uh in order to
discuss an appropriate time scale for
looking at these Alternatives thank you
thank you chairman
um yes um councilor flatman was
obviously
um promoting the work that's been done
to help with the cost of living crisis
but one of the things that came up this
morning on a discussion of that was in
fact the lack of transport
whereby as we know Suffolk libraries for
example are providing warm space as are
many communities but that is absolutely
no point at all of them doing that if
people have no act means of of transport
to get to those places
yeah the question is will that be part
of the consultation and will that be
part of the work that the cost of living
support team are looking into please
thank you councilor
important things about people wanting to
get warm places uh is look we need to
have better promotion of the connecting
communities
um scheme because it is not well
promoted a lot of people who probably
have in greatest need of using
connecting communities don't know either
don't know it exists or don't know how
to actually make contact with them this
came up through the work that the rural
Transport taskervillage Group did so I
think promoting promoting that scheme
would be a step forward
um uh and and yes it is something we can
take into account but this is a crisis
now it's not it's not a crisis that
we're predicting is going to happen in
in six months or 12 months time when
we've actually got the electric bus up
and running it's something that needs to
be done now and I think we need to speak
with our our well we have already spoken
with our County Council colleagues about
promoting connecting communities thank
you thank you councilor wellum are there
any further questions
would you like to add anything before we
finish this item no that's fine thank
you very much chair okay thank you very
much Council
so item 10 recommendations from cabinet
or committees so we go on to item 10A
Jac
2133 the annual treasury management
report 2021 2022 I'd like to invite
Council Muller to introduce this item
and to move the recommendations on the
agenda
very much chair
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
outturn for the financial year 2021-22
it provides details of the performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities including the regulatory
framework economic conditions interest
rate and liquidity risk major issues
over the period were the economic
recovery from the coronavirus pandemic
the war in Ukraine higher inflation and
higher interest rates
the CPI was 0.7 in March 2021 but
thereafter began to steadily increase
surges in wholesale gas and electricity
prices led to the CPI for February 2022
as 6.2 year on year up from 5.5 in the
previous month
bank rate was 0.10 at the beginning of
the reporting period however to combat
Rising inflation the bank of England
increased it to 0.75 by March 2022
the government's furlough scheme had
insulated the labor market from the
worst effects of the pandemic having
peaked it 5.2 percent in December 2020
unemployment continued to fall and the
labor market data for the three months
to January 2022 show the unemployment
rate at 3.9 percent
more specifically for mid-suffolk first
the council continue to hold additional
cash from government grants receive
relating to covert 19. this has
increased treasury investment activity
during the year
secondly regarding banking activities
the council operated within the daily
bank account limits third the council
has decreased its debt by 7.2 million
pounds fourth a further 4.5 million was
lent to Gateway 14 Limited
fifth all investment activities
undertaken were in accordance with the
approved counterparty list except for
one occasion when the council exceed as
its investment limits in two of its
money market funds by 500k as mentioned
in appendix C power of 4.1 the position
was resolved the next day the process
has been revised to include individual
fund balances as part of the approval
process
six the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
in appendix C of the report
the council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure the
investment activity undertaken for the
year was done so in priority order of
security and liquidity over yield as
prescribed in the treasury management
strategy
if you have any questions we will be
happy to recommend them and the
recommendations can be found on page
four and their items
um 3.1 3.2 and 3.4 and can I ask for a
second but please check thank you
thank you I'm happy to Second and
reserve my right to speak
move to questions
are there any questions councilor field
thank you sue
return to the question before a slightly
different form
the question really is what is the
impact on the treasury management with
councils the substantial increase in
interest rates that's occurring at the
moment
short-term borrowing of the council is
reported on page 34s being
30.9 million pounds
and I keep losing my screen sorry to be
a nuisance
it'll be 30
30.5 million pounds at
0.2 percent
um and uh the current interest rate is
around 4.1 percent the difference in
that is about 1.2 Millions per per annum
so really looking for an indication from
from the financial officers or yourself
as to what sort of impact we expect that
to have on the council and does that
number the 30.9 million include the
borrowings the short-term borrowings we
have for sifco and the full Gateway 14
or is it
just call Council business thank you
thank you Phil um could I ask the
director for corporate resources Melissa
Evans please to to answer that question
thank
you thank you thank you thank you
councilor Phil for your question
um I guess it kind of relates to the the
question you had earlier so I'll I'll
answer that now if that's okay
um if we were to do a like for like
replacement of the borrowing we have at
the moment and we have done some very
rough calculations it's about an
increase of 800 000 pounds for next year
however I'd like to caveat that is
saying the borrowing that we have at the
moment is likely to reduce going forward
as a result of other Investments that
we've got in terms of our Capital
program things like Gateway 14 we're
likely to see some income coming back
from that so I don't expect our
borrowing to be that right going forward
so but we are working on the
calculations but we're bringing
something back for the budget
thank you very much chairman and I don't
know whether you'll be able to answer
this one for me Dave but happy to have
an email answer or hand on to the the
team over there
um some of us will remember that term
several years ago there was a debate
about ethical Investments and so on and
keeping money over here and the problems
that affected I think it was egg and
various Council investing in Icelandic
Banks and it will turn to ashes just as
a reassurance I'd just like to know that
type of risk is taken fully into account
I've always taken The View with
taxpayers pound notes it belongs to us
all here we don't pay fast and loose and
we certainly kept all the investments in
here and also I see in the report there
which I thought was very comprehensive
so thanks for that there is an emphasis
on green that doesn't actually say
ethical investment but I can remember
before there were discussions about
putting it into the co-op bank because
it was thought to be more ethical but
unfortunately we all know what happened
to that how is that sort of accounted
for and if you are investing in some
other
funds that might be slightly more risky
how was that all taken into account and
balances so I'm happy to have a written
answer later if that's not appropriate
now I just wanted to raise that because
I think people need to be aware
sometimes
um you've got to get the balance right
and it was taxpayers money thank you
very much thank you Council Miller would
you like to refer that to the um
director for corporate resources uh yes
I would please thank you the director
for corporate Brazil
thank you um and if I made there was
quite a lot in there so if you if you'd
like me to take that away and I have I
can take that but I'd like to give you a
more thorough robust answer rather than
sort of giving you something off the
cuff if I can
thank you councilor even
very much chair
um I was just checking that there's
exactly the same as the previous um
reports I am on this committee and this
is something that I did raise at the
time in the committee meeting on at 11.3
um we talk about environmental social
and governance considerations ESG
um and it refers to the cabinet pushing
its fund managers
um in this regard and my question please
is what how how are we getting on with
that push for fund managers to take um
fees into
um consideration thank you chair thank
you the director for corporate resources
um our attentions have been focused on
sort of securing our borrowing at the
moment so not to say we've taken our eye
off the ball in that we definitely know
it's something we need to revisit with
our treasury of violence that I'll
enclose so we will be doing that in due
course
thank you very much and I can see oh
councilor Matheson
thank you Chet yeah the the
um obviously we've been had particular
difficulties with with the sort of
timetable of meetings and stuff this
year but I I have a more General
um feeling that we're not getting
financial and performance information to
all members in a sufficiently timely way
that members can evaluate what's going
on and so obviously in this case here we
are at the end of October looking at the
year ended last last March
um can we can we look at ways of of
actually getting at least preliminary
information to all members
um quite a lot quicker please
I'll put that to the director for
corporate resources
um maybe councilor Mathison we could
have a conversation outside of this as a
sort of information you'd like and we
can we can follow that up
more than happy to do that
thank you very much and I can't see any
further questions so I'll take this to
um debate if counselors would like to
speak once for no more than three
minutes if there's any counselors that
want to make any statements for debate
nope so um councilor Muller would you
like to add anything
okay thanks a lot so um I would now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civil office to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for councilors to cost their vote
foreign
yes in favor thank you
chair that is 31 in favor that is
unanimous
thank you very much that's carried
so the next item on the agenda is item
11
mc2220 capital investment fund company
sifco Capital limited business trading
and performance report
2021-22 I'd like to welcome sir
Christopher Hayworth
chair cifco Capital Henry cook director
Mark sarginson director Jack Anders
manager and enzas and Nigel Gorda
directive director of strategic Asset
Management jll
counselors I would like to deal with
this item in the open part of the agenda
if it's possible we can move to the
closed session if um councils deem it
necessary but if if we could try to
avoid this with the detail of our
questioning
um that would that would be um I'd
prefer that so um
I'd like to invite councilor Gould to
introduce paper
mc2220 and move the recommendations on
the report councilor Gould
thank you very much chairman uh I'm
delighted to introduce this report to
council today
it'll be somewhat later than originally
planned and indeed after uh almost four
months uh when the overview and scrutiny
committee uh looked at it in June as uh
as is being said
um the sipco business plan looks at
performance during the 2122 Financial
year and sets key performance indicators
and the direction of travel for the 2223
Financial year
during 2122 cifco continued to deliver
much needed income to the council and
also made a significant profit with the
value of the portfolio growing by some
12 percent
whilst the current uh economic climate
is uncertain sifco has proved to be well
managed and resilient in the face of
challenging conditions such as the
pandemic and it will continue to do so
as it faces the current challenges of
inflation higher interest rate and the
cost of living crisis
uh cifco invested in the portfolio
during the last Financial year to
improve the quality and sustainability
credentials of the portfolio including
the installation of solar panels and is
committed to continuing to improve the
sustainability of the portfolio
uh mid-suffolk District Council
benefited benefited from around 1.7
million pounds of net income last year a
total of four million pounds since sipco
started trading in 2017 all of which can
be put into our services helping our
communities and is particularly
important at the current time
uh there are three recommendations in
the report and they're set out in
section three uh as has been said by the
chair very few in scrutiny
um there was actually a I call a
protracted discussion about uh the
proposal or the consideration whether it
should go not come to the council unless
there was a particular issue therefore
which species you raise or should it
get continuous present to a review and
scrutiny and and and to to council and
congratulate uh the chair of overview on
scrutiny on navigating that discussion I
wasn't sure we were going to do it at
one point but it got to uh to a a
resolution in the end I'm just going to
read that out and I'd like to replace
the published the printed recommendation
three with this new 3.3 which which is
exactly an accord with the resolution of
of in scrutiny and that is that future
sifco business plans continue to be
scrutinized by the council
joint overview and scrutiny and then
reported to council as recommended by
The Joint overview excruciating
committee so
um I'm hoping that the council will will
endorse that I think one of the I just
finished by saying uh one of the really
important things I think about cifco is
that it is transparent we are
transparent as much as commercial
constraints to that in what is a very
valuable part of the council's revenue
stream
the chairman has made the introduction
we have as I said before an array an
impressive array of expertise and it is
that expertise
that certainly gives me and gives the
council confidence
in the resilience and future success of
of sifco so German I'm happy to take any
questions but are far more like to not
those questions towards the array of
experts thank you very much
thank you very much can I have a second
councilor mayor which are very happy to
second
and preserve my right
okay thank you so we'll go to questions
and we will direct the questions to
councilor Gould or the um director of
assets and Investments and her array of
expertise so do we have any questions
councilor Passmore thank you very much
chairman I was interested to see you at
um I think it's 13.1 the comment about
sustainability I was going to ask maybe
yourself Peter one of the large team of
experts there when you're assessing
sustainability for investment and so on
I'm just interested to know how that
might actually work for me personally
just to try and help you there we need a
pragmatic solution for me it's about
better use of scarcenet resources does
that affect who you put in there who you
rented out to or during the construction
or how do you get the mix between which
buildings you invest in and so on in
order to fulfill that laudable aim as
long as it's clearly pragmatic and I
think you probably know where I'm coming
from thank you thank you councilor Gould
I'll have a first stab and then nod it
onwards as I as I promise I think um you
know the the company has adopted the
council's adopted her sustainability
strategy in relation to this bit the
primary object of uh sifco is to provide
that valuable Revenue stream to to the
council there are some we we do what we
can in relation uh to improve the
sustainability of the portfolio the last
constraints around that
um the nature of the leases that we have
as well which uh puts the responsibility
on to tenant rather than ourselves but I
don't know whether the director of
assets and Investments would wish to add
to that
thank you cancer girls and yes as
councilor gold has said um sifco's
um policy around sustainability is
ensuring that the assets that we hold uh
deliver both a financial return but also
address
um reducing
um impact on the environment and so it's
interesting that
um we have had some opportunities to be
able to enhance the value of
within the portfolio whilst also
improving its sustainability credentials
so the refurbishment works that were
undertaken at Pasadena way in Harlow and
did just that really it enhanced the
capital value of the property whilst
also
um reducing its uh or improving its EPC
rating so we use the EPC rating data to
to monitor our Effectiveness in that
space and
councilor gold is auto correct in saying
that
um it's a partnership really between the
landlord and tenant in terms of what
we're able to achieve we have leases
that govern that that provide the
governance in terms of who's responsible
for for the maintenance of the building
we need to work with those contractual
Arrangements we do have some very
positive discussions with our tenants
and are very open to conversations about
how we can work together to help to
improve the sustainability of any of the
buildings within the portfolio
question from councilor Willem
thank you chair
um
does sifco it's got to be a question I
can't make a statement so does cifco
have details of the EPC rating of all
its buildings and can cifco move faster
to improve the EPC ratings of all its
buildings
somewhere in all of these buildings
thank you councilor yes we do have EPC
data for all of our buildings
um
and
um we are making some substantial
progress in terms of improving uh the
the ratings of our properties so you'll
note within the business plan that we've
proposed a new kpi this year in relation
to sustainability and seeking to improve
the EPC rating within our entire
portfolio so that we have C ratings or
above by 2027 that aligns with the
government
um
that changes to the means legislation
and that's why the kpi has been set in
that way but as I mentioned before we do
need to work with tenants to deliver
those improvements so it needs to be
done in a a managed and an appropriate
Pace to move forward those improvements
found
thank you and she was going to mention
the EPC ratings I I know it is a
government requirement that they be
increased to be and that you state that
you're refunding those from um the
company's capital and it's considerably
number of buildings clearly need
improving and the ones you've worked on
so far the cost is quite High
so I was discussing a question are you
um how sure are you okay can you justify
to us that you can actually meet that
money out of the company's
rental income while at the same time
meeting interest payments to this
Council and of course not undertaking
extra borrowing as that seems to be
banned under various um new Financial
models that have been placed upon us
the right dress
into your cancer field
um so in terms of EPC improvements
um some of the measures that are
required are actually quite small so the
ones we've talked about in in the report
this year have been some of the larger
Investments that have needed to be
undertaken such as the work that
Pasadena away and Harlow a number of the
improvements are actually
um a sort of lower value I suppose or
lower cost improvements we are working
through the portfolio in a um in a sort
of measured way
um dealing with a proportion at a time
some of the works will be the
responsibility of the landlord some of
the works will be the responsibility of
the tenant to see those improvements
come forward and longer term we will
need to review potentially some of the
bigger projects that might need further
investment and how those are funded but
the current program that we're looking
at is fundable through sifco
thank you very much and I don't believe
there's any further questions so I'll
move to debates and the same rules apply
and please speak once for no more than
three minutes would anyone like to start
the debate
councilor Mellon
thank you chair
um
so we've heard that the report we have
before us today is already somewhere out
of date
called from the agenda of our July
meeting and then as we know our planned
September meeting was postponed to due
to the death of the queen so we're
looking back at a report prepared some
time ago
and we're already part way through the
year to which the business plan refers
so and I'll hardly need to remind
Council that the the last few months
have not been the most economically
stable period in Britain's history
we've had the war in Ukraine we've had
steep rises in energy and food prices
and we've had changes in the political
leadership in Westminster and then
changes back
and we've seen interest rates go back up
towards historic norms and now the
effects of these uncertainties will no
doubt be seen in the report of the
current Year's trading which I hope we
will examine much earlier
next year
this opposition has always held an
objection in principle to the concept of
borrowing money from the public works
loan board and using it to purchase
commercial property
and I restate that now
and of course we then found that the
government agreed with us and it has
stopped up this lending route
now clearly we are now moving into a
time of great uncertainty in the economy
in the tax system
inflation over 10 percent
and interest rates going up
so whilst we can welcome the reported
performance of sifco over the previous
year the question really is still this
can sifco Thrive can it still perform
In This Very changed environment
notwithstanding the excellent staff and
advisors we have
now for the sake of our residents I hope
that it can
but for me it remains an open question
that will only be answered with time
so whilst I'm happy to note the trading
activity and performance I'm still not
keen to vote in favor of the the
business plan for the future and I
prefer if we could possibly take those
items separately thank you Jim
councilor mayor
thanks chair
um
he won't surprise the chamber that I
take a quite different View
but I would refer you to page 99
page 99 has a diagram on it that I think
is
his core of what we do on that that
diagram shows
property companies over a period
Capital values will go up and down
but look at the revenue
it's been steady for 40 years
and that is what sifco is it generates
Revenue I'm sure our Capital values will
go up and down
they're three million ahead of what we
pay for them but that may change
but it's the revenue that we want that
revenue is real money that we can spend
on anything we want to support our
residents
I would like to get to the position
where cifco becomes non-contentious
there are many things this Council has
decided upon before I became a counselor
and sifco was created before many of us
we're here
sifco is performing it's working well we
have a fantastic team running it and I
Leave myself out of that team
it will deliver income in the years to
come real income that we can spend on
our residents
so I look forward to enjoying that
income over the next
2071 we pay off the loan
if the odd years of 1.7 million pounds
is a lot of money plus then the capital
values on top
parents generation in you know they gave
me and most of us here the debts of the
second world war payoff
we have now given our kids the coveted
debt and goodness knows what other debts
they've got to pay off
Isn't it nice to see sifco being a gift
that we can give future Generations
we're giving them money we're giving
them a real solid asset that they can
use
so I truly believe that cifco will
continue to deliver thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much chairman
um yes I think the time for debate about
whether sifco should be there or not
that debate has happened to finish I
accept I had reservations that's fine
but now is the time to get right behind
this it's an excellent report so thank
you very much for that and we need to do
everything we damn well can to make sure
it's success provides the revenue
streams that we do for the future
benefit of our taxpayers so I wish you
all the best and I mean that most
sincerely the
um I suppose the variety of Investments
trying to reduce the risk I think is
really important and very pleased to see
that as regards this this is a long-term
investment and as you rightly say Rick
valuations go up and down but therefore
there's this degree of trust I can see
you've had all sorts of advice managing
the risk is always a complicated
business one only has to look for
example at the bank of England's
forecasts and so on to say that there is
a element of criticism that some of us
would have had regarding their interest
rate management throwing money at the
system I think they should have raised
interest rates six seven maybe eight
months ago but we are where we are so as
we are here now let's do everything
possible to support this this company
this organization and making the
Investments I think the results are very
very good so I congratulate you on that
and hope that that will continue because
it is going to benefit people in the
future so let's look forwards and not
backwards thank you chairman
um thank you very much chair and just to
um affirm as I always do with my my
comments are not a reflection on on the
staff and the professional advisors who
work hard on in the in this regard
they're purely aimed at the um
councilors who've you know made made
those decisions and still make the
decisions but I'd just like to remind
people that the liability for this rests
on our taxpayers on on all taxpayers on
our residents and on our businesses and
if we're going to borrow
um for for that we just need to always
keep that in mind and I think with that
perspective
one of the big concerns is about risk
and I don't think we talk enough about
risk or even even see enough about it in
this chamber and I'd Echo the comments
that these um you know the documents
that we're looking at here are well out
of date and perhaps
um those listening that are involved
more um closely with the work of sifco
can think on that and actually perhaps
bring some updates in terms of
particularly the The Current financial
mess that our UK government seems to
have got us into
and I think what by the at the ultimate
Point really is that if we're going to
be borrowing you know investing we still
need to be investing in our own District
not investing in in Epsom in Southampton
in Coventry and I would really hope that
in the future that we can shift some of
those sifco
properties into one's closer to home and
then I feel a lot more comfortable with
the overall
um
the overall project as it were thank you
very much
thank you
already people that want to say anymore
oh councilor Gould would you like to sum
up please thanks yeah and and just
briefly uh if I may chairman
um
starting with
um councilor Ebert's uh comment about a
rather invest in a district that in
businesses elsewhere
actually what we're getting those
businesses elsewhere to do is to invest
in mid-suffolk there's something sweet
about uh getting businesses Milton
Keynes or wherever it might be to spend
their money here so we can look at
projects such as warm places whatever it
might be uh and I I find that uh a most
satisfying thought that's why we are not
investing in those businesses we are
getting them to pay money to us that we
invest in our place
uh in terms of
um both councilman and cancer even
mentioned uh about active date
can I in
into
looking at the cifco website because
there you will see uh regular and
quarterly updates uh on on performance
in that itself looking at that is a very
good website I have to say if looking at
that prompts any questions then we're
more than happy uh to to pick those up
so in terms of the the challenges upon
us uh I did I had to say I've become
concerned about it soon after taking off
over the portfolio there was covid uh I
now we've had a European War uh the
succos of living crisis is it I it did
take me to the uh Old Testament book of
Exodus says to check just how many
plagues Egypt had to put up with and it
was only 10. so he must be well on our
way through that list uh by by now but I
go back to the uh my answer to cancer
Fields uh very pertinent question uh in
the agenda which uh and the answer I
gave which is about the resilience of
our our Investment Portfolio its
diversity
um the way we go about
um uh checking the covenants of of
clients the things that actually uh give
us that 98 uh rent return which is above
the above the industry uh average
considerably above so yes there are
risks we will continue to manage
understand and manage those risks as
cancers may have said we will continue
to enjoy the revenue stream uh that
that's investment brings and if at the
end of it I don't think I'll be here
when when we finish paying off the debt
but
um that don't just mean in this Council
chamber but uh but hopefully there will
be a substantial the people that are in
this district will enjoy the benefits of
a substantial Capital payoff thank you
very much chairman
thank you councilor Gould
[Applause]
thank you I will now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct an electronic vote I'm sorry
please
well I am I didn't hear many people in
the debate I
well it was asked at the outset
um
I can do it as a show of hands
in the chamber and this a show of hands
to um
to um four splitting the recommendations
into three separate votes and we do a
count so if you'd like to those split
please put your hand up
15.
um
okay so um if you would if you'd like to
um not do them on in separate them and
do them on block please raise your hand
and my vote yeah sorry
right okay so we will do them on block
thank you
so I'll ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
an electronic vote
put your vote please
Council Pratt can I take your vote
please against
thank you
chair that is 16 4 and 15 against
oh sorry is this a point of order
we'll um we'll deal with that thank you
very much councilor field
foreign
thank you right so now we'll move on to
item 15
mc221 the and sorry if the um sifco
board would like to leave at this point
you're welcome to I'm leaving thank you
very much for participating in this
meeting and coming
right we'll carry on with the agenda
thank you very much item 15
mc221 joint local development scheme
2022 to 2025
I would like to invite councilor burn to
introduce paper
mc221 and to move the recommendations on
in the report
councilor Byrne
thank you chairman
um
this introduction that I'm going to read
out to you um
uh has has gone through an iteration or
two since it was first drafted and um
it's benefited from those
particularly from input from my
counterpart at Labor District Council
Clary barthy councilor Clive arthy who
is Cabinet member for planning at Labor
and I'd like to thank him for the tweaks
that he's introduced into this
uh baby and met suffolk's last joint
local development scheme or LDS as we
know it was published in July 2020
in late 2020 both councils approved the
joint local plan pre-submission document
which was submitted to the then
Secretary of State for housing
communities and the local government for
independent examination in early 2021.
as I'm sure you're aware a significant
amount of work has been undertaken
through the examination to reach where
we are today
following hearings held last year and
subsequent Communications with the
appointed planning inspectors
The Joint local plan jlp is to be taken
forward in two parts part one has been
subject to discussion letter examination
and is currently at the modification
stage prior to the next consultation on
the modifications
work on part two has also commenced
we need formally to review the LDS which
is the work program for update prior to
the part one modifications consultation
com commencing
I'll give you some background the LDS
sets out the local planning Authority's
work program for the preparation of the
development plan documents over the
period between 2022 and 2025.
we need to have an update to the LDS
prior to the consultation on
modifications to the part 1 jlp which is
currently anticipated to begin in late
autumn
there is also a legal requirement to
have an update to LDS up-to-date LDS in
place prior to the adoption of a local
plan
for the LDS content the LDS formally
introduces a part one and part two joint
local plan as agreed during the
examination at a meeting held with the
inspectors last year
the LDS also introduces a number of
supplementary planning documents spds to
follow adoption of a part one joint
local plan
and to provide more detail on the
implementation of the planning policies
within it
and revised timetable is also presented
for a review of the community
infrastructure Levy that's still
charging schedules
the LDS identifies that A Part 2 local
plan joint local plan will follow the
part one document and will contain
an up-to-date settlement hierarchy
a special Distribution on of any housing
allocations
a housing requirement figures for the
neighborhood plan areas
individual site allocations
to date settlement boundaries reflecting
commitments and site allocations
open space designations with a relevant
development management policy
an up-to-date assessment accommodation
needs for gypsies Travelers traveling
show people and boat dwellers together
with relevant development management
policies and if necessary allocations to
provide for this need
the indicative time scale outlines the
stages that are necessary for the
preparation of this development plan
document
which will involve at least three stages
of public consultation prior to
submission for examination
nine supplementary planning documents
are introduced with an initial focus on
affordable housing
biodiversity and trees well-being and
health and sustainable Construction
we need to bring this LDS into effect by
the 31st of October to ensure that the
progress being made on the jlp can
continue in accordance with the current
timetable to modifications consultation
and ultimately adoption next year
so therefore I'm proposing the
recommendations at 3.1 that the baber
and mid-suffolk Joint local development
scheme 2022-25
uh October 22 2022 appendix a is agreed
to be brought into effect from the 31st
of October and I look for second thank
you
yes I'm very happy to second that and
reserve the right to speak if necessary
thank you very much
okay thank you very much I'll I'll now
move to um questions
um please keep the questions in regards
to the recommendation we're talking
about which is a timetable and um the
titles of the report not individual
details and what should be within the
spds
um yeah counts the field
thank you chair
I note that overall process will not be
finished until 2025
that's that's of the part two of the
plan which
originally was incorporated Within part
one
I don't know how many times one's made
the point to communities that it's
absolutely essential we have these
planets in place
so the question is really can a
portfolio holder assure us
that the right resources the right
number of people the right talents and
the right amount of effort are available
to ensure that this program does not go
back yet again thank you
all right
um yes I I can I can give you the
Assurance as as things stand today I
hope sincerely that we can we can
maintain the timetable that is set out
there
um I think you probably feel more
reassured if I ask um
uh the director to
give
his view on that particular question if
you wouldn't mind
thank you
thank you chair and thank you councilor
field for the question
um I'm confident that we have sufficient
budget available to us to secure the
necessary resource and we take a a
creative approach to ensuring that we
can secure the necessary offices in
order to fulfill the work required is a
challenging environment planners are
short in Supply but we do everything
that we can and we have a full
complement of staff at the moment
councilor e-burn
um thank you very much chair my question
was similar to councilor field but if we
are if we add any other spds to this
list and when we've already I'm not sure
that um solar Farms was going to be
added but there are things that come up
that we will add to that and so what
really will the will it come back again
if there's something else added to it or
will that just be included in
um as part of the work and therefore
will any of the resource issues or
potential resource issues not saying
there's a resource issue at the moment
any potential resources should be
covered still or or whether that's doing
it in-house or using Consultants
whatever thank you chair
councilor burn
thank you um well as as I understand it
um
we are not obliged to include
spds within the
um LDS
So to that extent there is a degree of
flexibility
as to
a how we schedule them and B how we
introduce
which ones to to pursue although we have
committed to pursuing the ones that are
already listed
were we to want to pursue any more than
that I think we'd
look very closely at our existing
resources and wonder whether perhaps we
would need to
bring in additional resource for any
more than that but we have control over
that situation it's not an obligatory
part of an LDS but we did think that for
the sake of completeness and for for
total transparency so that you could see
all see everybody could see exactly what
was going on in connection with our
planning policy and the implementation
of the glp that we would include spds
into it as well does that help
thank you a question from councilor Emma
Rosen
I might be misunderstanding so apologies
if so I noticed that
um most of the spds have a period of
public consultation but don't have a
period of uh of modification so do we
expect that any public consultation will
not lead to any modifications
Council burn
or would you like to refer the question
I I I I think I will for detail but I
mean my understanding is that the
consultations will inform modification
uh and that that we will as uh certainly
as a covenant if not a full Council well
full Council eventually will will give
give
approval to these spds
um but would you like to add to that to
Rob please corporate manager for
apparent policies
thank you chair um yeah the
clarification is the modifications in
respect to development plan documents at
the Joint local plan a formal
consultation on those modifications the
public consultation on submission paying
documents of course Commerce come back
to us we consider those comments and
then we take the document back to full
Council for adoption detailing how those
comments have been taken into account
thank you
councilor Stringer
thank you chairman uh
just want to focus what's on in the list
of part two and it says Within part two
that there will be housing requirement
figures for neighborhood plan areas
giving that some neighbor original
neighborhood plans are now being
Revisited and uh and and reappraised now
uh
this document's going to be worked on as
it were next year
also coupled with the fact that part two
is not only going to assess the needs
for gypsies Travelers show people Etc
but also then call for sites and
allocations if needed
is there sufficient time is that
timetable on part two a realistic one I
think is what I'm asking
[Music]
tempted
and say yes
but I I will I will I will cross I will
pass that one over if you don't mind
thank you
chairman of the thank you Council
Stringer
yes
the
timetable is realistic there has been
pressure um exerted as you will all be
aware all counselors know that the
sincere pressure that your community is
feel for us to adopt and deliver a local
plan as quickly as possible through the
examination we've seen some of the risks
of running too quickly at some of these
things so part two has been
programmed to ensure that we are
delivering at the fastest possible Pace
while also recognizing the need for
quality assurance as part of the process
so it has been realistically planned and
programmed
um I yeah would you like a supplement
yeah there's just another question at
least on and I appreciate the uh the
response
uh it just seems yeah incredibly tight
in terms of uh I would I was expecting
to see
allocations or call for sites that were
done in part one in line with the the
settled part of the community but that
that's not a problem uh what I wanted to
know and and you should be able to
answer the question in the first table
on part two
we're then going to provide up-to-date
settlement boundaries
in that which
obviously we've got a set going in in
the existing documents reflecting
commitments and site allocations I'd
actually think my question is what's the
difference between the commitment and a
site allocation
thank you chair our commitment refers to
something Scott filing commission
already
councilor wellum
thank you chair
um one thing which concerns me as
representing an area where there have
been lots of planning applications
um most of them approved against the
wishes of the residents that we might
when this timetable becomes better known
we might get a flurry of applications
for unsuitable sites in the very same
Villages that have suffered from them in
the past so can you give me any
assurance that we're that that we're not
going to get a flurry of applications
thank you
no of course not we can't give that sort
of assurance but it's completely out of
the council's control
that depends depends in early on
developers and
what they how they wish to spend their
time and spend their money so
if if that was the wording that you the
considered wording of your question
councilor Willem then I I can only give
you no as an answer
um okay councilor welcome yeah but do
you think we're do you think we're in a
sound position to turn down such
applications if they're on unsuitable
sites because we've suffered a lot in
the past are we in a better position are
we in a better position or a worse
position as a result of that longer time
frame
that one I think I would like to pass
over charity if you don't mind
thank you chair um having the part one
in place will give a stronger protection
of today planning policies and then we
also are just about to finish
consultation on the housing land supply
of 10.88 years so I'd argue we're in a
stronger position now than we were in a
few years back thank you
well we'll move to debate um with the
same rules apply
if you would like to make a statement
once no more than three minutes long
would anyone like to start the debate
no okay um
councilor Byrne would you like to add
anything at this point
um
I don't think so chair that's been quite
quite well aired from my point of view
I'm pleased to say that the
beaver District Council
approved the recommendation at its
meeting on Wednesday and I I hope that
we will we will do the same thank you
very much
thank you so I'll um now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct an electronic vote
thank you chair that voted
voted across their vote
Council Pratt can I take your vote yeah
I'm in favor thank you
yes of course can I take
thank you
chair that is 31 4 that is unanimous
okay thank you that's carried
um
we
we're an hour and 45 minutes into the
meeting now
I can I ask for a show of hands if
anyone would like to have a five minute
break before we carry on with the rest
of the agenda
I think that's enough
I won't worry that it's a majority but
I'll say that people would like a
breakthrough thank you so that's five
minutes
awesome
okay
thank you very much I'll um now move to
um item 16. the
mc222 appointment to the independent
persons for code of conduct complaints
I'd like to invite our new monitoring
officer to introduce this report
thank you
thank you Joe
um so in accordance with the localism
ACT 2011
um there's a duty upon the council to
promote a high standards of conduct and
uh well high standards so in accordance
with that there is a arrangements to
deal with any complaints and in
accordance further in accordance with
that where there's a requirement to have
independent persons under Section 28 28
3 of the localism act so that's what
that's what the paper is about today
just to explain a little bit about the
process so there were applications where
adverts went out
went out the closing date was around
August of this year there were some 20
applicants that came forward of those 20
shortlisted down to eight
for interview and out of those eight
five were appointed and all eminently
appointable
so unless anyone has any questions
I'll leave I'll leave the chair to find
it proposal under a secular
okay thank you yeah all of them could I
have a proposal for that councilor
Morley and the second year was that
councilor flatland councilman
thank you
um so this you do you have a question
Council Richardson no I was just
prepared to secondly oh okay now I've
got a second there thank you
um councilor flattman beat you to it so
um
a question from councilor Morrison
uh just quick question
um in the appointment how was was
impartiality a uh
uh a shoe that was addressed and how how
might it be how might it have been
addressed
how was the address
yes
can I can I can I defer to jam please
thank you yeah so um I was part of the
interview panel and um all of our um
applicants went through our normal
recruitment process which which we don't
know who they are until we actually get
to the interview and so it is an
impartial process they had a set of
questions and the best applicants for
the Post were chosen from the interview
questions
no so um wheelam will move to the debate
um part of this it is the question of
process so I don't expect
too too many people making statements in
the debate but I will I will open it to
councilor Morley
as I understand thank you chair as I
understand it mid-suffic is the final
Council in Suffolk that has not yet
approved this so it's my hope that
you're going to support this and vote
for approval thank you
thank you very much and we'll now ask
the corporate manager governance and
Civic office to conduct the electronic
vote
sure that is showing in blue for you to
cast your vote
councilor Pratt can I take your vote
please yeah four thank you
Council Carter did you wish to place
your vote
apparent my hand is too scared
then it's there
thank you
so chair that is 30 votes for
2223 draft timetable of committee
meetings 2023 to 2024
I would like to invite councilor Morley
to introduce paper
mc223 and to move the recommendations in
the report
councilor Morley
thank you chair yes this is the um draft
timetable for the year commencing in May
it's important that we get this approved
so that it can get into people's Diaries
and officers can start booking rooms
ahead of May otherwise we won't have any
rooms for our meetings so um
thank you that's all I want to say on
that
thank you very much do I have a second
counselor haddenham
no problem unless anyone has any
questions
thank you chair I'm not
questionable
what's an observation the timetable
shows separate with Suffolk District
Council overview and scrutiny meetings
and baber District Council overview and
security meetings work as has been the
case in the the current year and
previous years but but most of the
meetings are joined
overview of security meetings and it's
almost at the last minute that the the
timetable shows that it's a joint
meeting can I just
suggestion that
next year's overview and security
meeting agrees its work plan early on
and gets the timetable changed early on
not
a few weeks before the meeting as has
been the case just recently
thank you
I think it was a question
we'll note that we um
thank you very much um Council staff
well firstly like to endorse what
councilor Wellen has said um can I ask a
question
has the timetable of meetings been
coordinated with Suffolk County
council's meetings I think this is
probably the usual uh case but can I
just have confirmation that that has
been considered thank you
um
that we have consulted with the county
and sometimes their meetings aren't so
far booked but we where we can we we do
plan with them ahead
thank you very much
um Council feel did you have a question
inform it as a question
a tradition on occasions like this for
me to ask well it has been a tradition
for 10 years to ask is there any
possibility that we might form this
calendar on the same Microsoft Outlook
so that we could all merge it with our
darling
diary without spending a lot of time
typing silly letters in or writing them
on pieces of paper
to sort of move to a bit more modern
technology
I'd just like to come back on that I
know cancer field has asked me that
every year and every year we come up
against the same problem it's the county
council's um firewall that prevents us
downloading into our Outlook calendars
and we have actually got a calendar in
modern.gov in the library what does
contain all the committee meetings and
the events of the council so Andy is
there we can send that link to
councilors but it is there for you to
use but unfortunately it won't transpose
itself into your Outlook calendar
college so I know to what you say but I
have a copy of your
Democratic service
calendar which does appear on my phone
so is it that
I could always find you an I.T person
who could fix it
um
councilor Morley would you like to reply
to this or are you asking a question
I'm so glad you asked me that question
councilorfield I can confirm that we
have been trialing sorry I have been
trialling
a virtual calendar and that's in the
process of being checked out at the
moment and I'll keep you informed as to
what's happening
we need to
no I will let you speak councilor
Mansell but I will say that um our
um Jan is very approachable outside of
this meeting for these little tweaks and
things they need to do and I'm sure no
one would begrudge a little tweak or a
mistake but
um yeah counselor man it was a point of
clarification actually because I have no
idea what a virtual calendar is so could
councilman just tell me what a virtual
calendar is I have a calendar uh it's
not virtual thank you
councilor Morley
[Music]
thank you very much I don't think we
need to debate this I think we can take
this straight to the boat so
um
thank you very much I'll ask the
corporate manager for governance and
Civic office
um to conduct the electronic
showing in blue for you to cast your
votes
Council Pratt can I take your vote
please in favor
thank you
counselor Norris are you having
um
technical
thank you
chair that is 31 in favor thank you
that's carried
the next item is 18
mc224 decisions taken by the chief
executive
did the corporate
Corpus 34 sorry
34 in favor
thank you very much so
item 18
mc224 decisions taken by the chief
executive under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution I'd like to invite the
chief executive to introduce the report
which is for ratification
thank you chairman and good evening
councilors as councilors will be aware
your previous monitoring officer Emily
Ewell left the organization at the
beginning of this month you are obliged
to have a monitoring officer and so in
the absence of a full council meeting
I've used my powers of urgency in order
to appoint Mr Ali who you've already
heard from this evening but I'm asking
this evening that you formally ratify
that decision as it is more normal for
full Council to make the appointment of
the monitoring officer thank you Jim
thank you very much today have a
proposer for that councilor Fleming
thank you Council Fleming and a seconder
councilor Anthony
thank you very much
so the recommendation is that the
council ratifies the decision taken
under delegated powers by the chief
executive unless the members have any
questions I want to put straight to the
boat
attempted last year if we were to say no
would the interim monitor of the
interview no sorry
I might worry about that after the vote
so um yeah thank you I'll um now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct an electronic vote
thank you
thank you um chair that is now showing
in blue for you to cast your vote
now
as a pratt can I take your vote please
oh thank you
chair chair that is 30 votes for
thank you very much that's carried
if you just bear with me one minute
um
right item 19 is
mc225 recommendations from the
Independent remuneration
I would like to invite the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
introduce this report
of a review of the Council of scheme of
allowances by the independent
remuneration panel who are unfortunately
not able to be with us tonight
under the local authorities members
allowances England regulations 2003 the
regulations the council is required to
establish and maintain an independent
remuneration panel to make
recommendations to council about the
allowances to be paid to members it is
important that the council appoints an
independent remuneration panel and pays
due regard to the views of the panel
before any decisions are made in respect
of changes to the scheme of allowances
for members
as part of this review a questionnaire
was issued to all councilors to support
and inform the review responses were
received from 39 of the 69 current
cancers 59 response the information
obtained was helpful in informing the
irp's deliberations the IRP interviewed
eight current cancers using a structured
questioning process and held focus
groups across both authorities an
opportunity was also given for
individual councilors to be interviewed
if they wished or submit comments to the
panel
as part of their review the IRP also
examined the current scheme for both
authorities and highlighted differences
anomalies made and made comparative
reviews from other similar authorities
they also examined the report from the
previous review and took into account
the Cancer's role descriptions in terms
of reference
the panel also met with the chief
executive the irp's report and their
findings are detailed in appendix a of
the papers just need to draw your
attention to a typo on the front of the
report under recommendation two It
should read 5669
and wherever that is referenced I think
it's just the first two figures that
just
um just been put the wrong way around
um it should also be noted that the
review had taken place before the full
extent of the cost of living crisis was
known
as the previous scheme was back dated to
2017 to accommodate the changes in the
governance Arrangements the indexing for
the current schemes stopped in 2021
therefore there will be no uplift to the
councilor allowance scheme for this year
cancers will need to take these
effectors into account when considering
they put the report before them finally
I would like to thank the IRP panel for
their comprehensive review of the scheme
thank you
thank you
report is from the Independent
remuneration panel and not tabled by a
counselor I intend to move the
recommendations in the report myself and
ask for a second to counselor epineon
thank you chair and I'd be happy to
second that
thank you
councilor Morley I believe you have a
Amendment you'd like to table
thank you chair
as you all all know following the irp's
report a cross-party working group of
the two councils was set up to review
the panel's recommendations
as a result of this some changes were
deemed to be necessary and these can be
found in appendix F of the report
I would just like to summarize these
with the reasoning behind them
one the working group thought that the
public service discount a 40 recommended
by the panel was too high based on the
responses received from members
we have therefore reduced this to 35
percent and this has been applied to the
basic allowance and is propagated to
other allowances through the stated
multipliers
two the working group also wanted to
ensure that the annual uplift for the
current year is included in line with
local government pay Awards and so a six
percent increase equivalent to the
current officer inflation increase for
2022-23 has been included in the basic
allowance
three there was quite a bit of
discussion about the recommendation
concerning the number of sras an
individual counselor could claim
the working group thought that the
Restriction to just one was not
practical given the number of counselors
we now have
and also it didn't reflect the increased
workload that the councilor with more
than one responsibility has
it therefore decided to revise this to
be no more than two sras
and that's equivalent to how we operate
now
finally the working group wanted to
ensure that the revised allowance scheme
should only come into Force for the new
Council and so the effective date has
been put to 8th of May 2023
I would therefore like to propose the
the amended recommendations detailed in
appendix F and would call for a seconder
thank you
yeah I'm happy to second that and I'll
reserve my right to speak thank you
thank you and I accept the amendment as
proposed by Council
and young do you accept the amendment I
do also thank you thank you
um I will now ask councilors to vote
that this becomes that
is it sorry shall I carry on
I will now ask councilors to vote to
agree that this becomes the substantive
motion for questions and debate
um and I will ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
an electronic vote is this a point of
order
please
um do we not get the chance to
um debate the amendment yes that will be
next but we'll just make the amendment
the substantive motion we can't debate
whether we're going to vote for the the
amendment to be a substantive we're just
going to debate the motion after we
voted on whether this is going to be the
substantive motion yes please just vote
for this and then we'll um we'll move on
to um the substantive Nation
um right so um
thank you
um that is showing in blue for
cancers will need to scroll down a bit
yes counselor Eben thanks Joe I'm just a
bit concerned about the wording and that
because it says to accept the amended
recommendations couldn't it shouldn't it
not be just to accept the amendment
to become the substantive otherwise it
kind of I don't know how this is going
to appear in the minutes but it implies
if it could imply you've already voted
to accept these recommendations
do you want to change that
yes
thank you councilor even
so if you if you can all agree by show
of hands that we
um now debate and ask questions on the
the amendment that Council Morley has
put forward if we can all put your hands
up to vote for that
so that's carried
so um that now becomes a substantive
motion
um so we'll go to um questions and
um debate on that as the substantive
motion
do we have any questions
counselor Manson
you did say questions and debate yeah a
question yeah please um I've got a
couple of points um I'd like to make
um now in um I've lost the plot as to
what page we're on I'm sorry because
they keep me a lot of it is repeated but
I think I'm on appendix F section D
which is probably repeated elsewhere
about the travel and sustainable which
is subsistence allowances I just like to
make a comment about that now whilst I
completely appreciate that these are the
uh Inland revenues
um figures that we're using because
that's what we're allowed to have as a
sort of tax-free
um travel rate I'm assuming we don't
have to pay tax on it if it sticks to
that
um I think it is a great shame that we
are unable to increase the passenger
allowance
um to encourage more counselors to share
transport rather than everybody come in
a car with one person in it and I really
I I realize our hands are tied I just
wanted to make that comment that's my
first comment uh my second bit of the
debate is that I I'm disappointed that
we're not
um taking on board the views of the
independent remuneration panel more
fully
um because what is the point of having
an intimate in independent review if
we're then going to set aside some of
their recommendations
um and I do feel quite strongly about
this number of sras
so I'm not going to be voting for The
Proposal now that it's been amended
um because um what what was it councilor
Morley said she said that given the
number of counselors we've got we can't
have the Restriction to one SRA now I
remember this Council when we were
debating
uh the new number of councilors before
the last boundary review before the last
election
and we had lots of discussion about how
many councils we needed on this Council
to provide sufficient councilors on all
the Committees that we have
and here we are the leaders telling us
we now don't have enough counselors well
surely that part of the debate we should
have had back then in whenever it was
four or five years ago so we do have we
have sufficient councilors on this
Council to fulfill all of those roles
that require special responsibility
there shouldn't be a need for a vast
number of people to have
um more than one now
saying that
um I appreciate that there are a number
of people who are on a planning
committee and we can't have everybody
only having one if you count all the
planning committee members as well so I
see no reason why we can't have one SRA
excluding the planning committee
members allowance
um so um and I think that would be a
much fairer way of doing it uh when you
look at the responses that people gave
in the questionnaires about the amount
of hours they spend on Council business
I'm not I'm I'm not convinced that you
can actually have a sustainable and
healthy work-life balance if you are
taking on two special responsibilities
and doing the job thoroughly so I really
think that those special
responsibilities should be divvied up a
bit more
amenably so that there are there are
enough counselors on this Council that's
what we had that debate five years ago
so I won't be supporting this motion
I really see a little point in having an
independent remuneration panel and then
it being upgraded but the point I would
make the table on page 268 shows our
relative position roughly in the middle
of the comparative of 27 councils in
this area in
if we accept
that we are going to increase the basic
allowance to 6510 we shoot up in fact to
Fourth position now whilst I would love
the council to be in a high position in
any comparative table I would like to
think that was in terms of service and
that kind of thing and and and and
rating uh rating the council I don't
like us speak
the top end of that table so I too won't
be voting for this I'm quite happy for
the independent remuneration panels
recommendations and I think if we if we
appoint such a panel then we shouldn't
ride rough shot over I accept that
various member groups have had some
input into this and their view is
somewhat different but I certainly won't
be voting for it thank you
thank you
Council councilor mayor
thanks Jay
um
different things floating through my
head
I don't have a problem
with the recommendations
I don't have a problem with two sras and
never done this before but speaking in
support of councilman there
um
he took on the leadership of the
ship opposition there
still has to read the hundreds of pages
of planning documentation so why
shouldn't he have two allowances if
they're completely unrelated
so are you speaking he's hit me I think
it's me
um
next point is
do the directors of our companies
shoulder responsibility
they do in the papers that we've got
before us tonight the director of sifco
actually get the cifco directors get a
list in the auditor's report about
responsibility Gateway 14 our directors
there are delivering a massive
investment project that is probably the
highest risk that this Council faces
do they shoulder responsibility yes they
do now it's my understanding that the
directors could not be part of this
review so to my mind there's a bit of
work missing
there's a danger that we're going to
create a dichotomy if you go down the
traditional route
you receive an allowance
if you become a director
your responsibilities aren't even
acknowledged
now I'm not suggesting that directors
should have an allowance I'm suggesting
that there's a piece of work to be done
to look at
side of the coin and I know and
understand there are issues around
directors who appoints them well to my
mind I was asked by this Council to be a
director of sifco and then sifco voted
me onto the board
so I think there's another piece of work
I'm happy to support this amendment but
I would like Assurance that that second
piece of work will indeed be done to
look at whether it's appropriate for
directors to receive any
like to invite the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to come back
because you did ask a question there
that you'd like to clarify so Chad I
just would like to clarify that the the
independent remuneration panel after the
comments that councils did make to them
in the workshops and the interviews did
take that matter into account and did
consider it but because
once the council pays councilors to be a
board member that then becomes a
disclosable bikini interest
they felt that was a conflict because
that would actually mean that every time
the companies was discussed if you were
a board member you would have to leave
the room so they left it where it was as
a conflict of interest
yeah
I worry that if something is difficult
you can set it aside to move the the
main body of the report forward that is
an issue
that needs to be looked at and I still
believe that that body of work needs to
be done because
directors we're going to get more
directors it's a growing
um
instance on this Council and
what are we going to say to new
councilors well for this work you
receive an allowance and for this work
you don't
that's crazy I know there's an issue but
it needs to be looked at in detail
otherwise you're going to get a
dichotomy and that's going to cause
problems in the future
thank you very much chair
um well I believe there was a
cross-party member group that did review
this
um and I thanked them for the input on
it just to get it clear I'm not hiding
behind anything I'm chair of planning
I'm chair of referrals I'm chair of
Licensing I'm chair of Licensing
subcommittee I do get two sras and I
would like to correct that I hope I do
my job thoroughly I spend an awful lot
of time doing them both and in fact
today I had licensing issues which
aren't within the committee but are in
the background work so I will be voting
for this and thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
did we take into account how it would
affect councilors on means tested
benefits
so actually having these higher rate
wages because believe if we want to have
more diverse Council because you'll want
to have more counselors
it is very considered very
ominous taking on a role which she got
four years of guaranteed when you
afterwards you have to apply for
benefits again straight down the bottom
and then have to wait another nine
months before you get here back to
actually get a new thing so have we
taken into account how it affects other
people fighting and have we insured but
we can get other councilors coming in
which waiting to be able to won't have
to scrap everything to do so
you so the IRP
um I didn't specifically look at
um means tested or benefit related
queries but they did look at what they
could do to help and encourage people to
become counselors but they had also to
wire up with the public service discount
and
um other various factors that um were
around socially I'd um so no they didn't
specifically look at that but they did
take into account what the median wage
was and um for the area and what they
could do to attract more people into the
beingcoming a counselor
thank you Council geek
I welcome the Russian
Council for that very reason to
encourage a wider group of people to
stand for election the kind of people
who are time rich but money poor and
can't afford to give much of their time
voluntarily it's also very welcome as a
generous Child Care allowance with no
maximum and that there's a parental
leave policy for councilors now I don't
really have a problem with having
several sras going to a single counselor
but I do have a problem with the reason
given by councilor Morley if the
administration don't have enough
counselors to run the council well there
is an obvious solution and that's to
share power between the two halves of
the council if the current
administration had used the expertise on
the other half of the council which of
course did attract a lot of votes then
there would have been plenty of
counselors to do the work and that would
have solved the problem I think
councilor Humphries
thank you Mr chair um just want to come
back on uh councilor um
Carter's point about being fair and
allowing things it also goes on to
counselor geek's point the third
remuneration principles within the
papers clearly states remune
remuneration should not be an incentive
for services counselor nor should lack
of remuneration be a barrier the basic
allowance should encourage people from a
wide range of backgrounds and we've
arrived a wide range of skills to serve
as local councilors those who
participate in and contribute to the
Democratic process should not suffer
unreasonable Financial disadvantage as a
result of doing so so we can serve the
independent board took that and that's
why they've applied those principles
when we come to the independent review
body it is in the defense independent
review body or panel that
basically gets all the information
listens to us and comes at a
recommendation like all recommendations
that's not Direction recommendation is
there to be debated which we're doing
right now and previously to come up with
the amendments to come up with a
solution we then vote vote upon so you
know they might have recommended
something but it is a recommendation we
don't have to apply it or follow it
finally
um just trying to cover my thoughts
where I'm going
um yeah that's a good point we've all
had an opportunity to say something
before tonight uh I think you said 59
didn't reply
59 took part so 59 was that chosen 59 or
59 that chose to get involved 59
involved
voluntarily so what 41 of which didn't
bother
and here we are
you had your chance we all had a chance
to speak early on
that's all I'm going to say
and count the past more yeah I think
so much chairman now I support this
recommendation and um there are the
reason I'd like to give that is because
I do think it does help those who stand
regardless of um income background age
and so on I think is really really
important
um and this therefore helps from that
point the other thing I say the smaller
ounce you get for doing it isn't about
making money out of it it does actually
improve accountability and I think that
is important and in the past
um I think before certainly before I was
elected in Andrew and one or two others
I believe I'm right and saying you're
used to get an attendance allowance and
people going and they shove off after
about half an hour not everybody of
course yeah we all remember that when
you Keith so I think it's a better
system and I think the fact there's been
a um a cross-party group on this as well
which has come up with the
recommendations and I have to say in the
past independent panel recommendations
have not always been taken up either for
other reasons so now I welcome this so I
should be supporting it I think it's
balanced I think it's fair it's
reasonable so not the questions that all
of us have said on both sides and um so
let's just get on with it
councilman
thank you chair yeah I I think that um
councilor Carter raises um quite an
interesting point and and it's conceded
that the panel hasn't taken that into
consideration particularly now I'm not
suggesting we should you know hold this
back
um while this is it looked into but I
suspect that the department of work and
pensions and the hmrc have got
some some
um some guidelines
for generally
addressing the issue of counselor
allowances and the benefits system
broadly and um I think that those
guidelines ought to be in front of the
panel when they're thinking about it
um not that I as I said that we
shouldn't hold it back now but on the
other hand I think it would be useful to
find out what is supposed to happen
because I think as I said I think it
would be a nationally
um provided
way of working but I don't know what it
is
thank you chairman uh
I've always found this subject really
quite difficult uh and since 2003 when I
was first elected along with Tim and
some others
whenever this issue came around
irrespective of what the figures said
it always rang untrue with me and those
that I serve that while sitting in
office I was voting for a rise of my own
allowance
and I made a pledge then and I've made
it ever since that I will never sit in
this chamber and vote for an increase in
my own allowance why I'm sitting in a
term
uh and I've done that because because of
our inability to get the timing right
so that you voted for what the incoming
Council will get
which for the first time in almost 20
years we've achieved in this document
can I have assurances that we're then
going to do this same process again
in four years time so that we don't sit
here again if any of us get reelected or
any of a stand uh to then be in that
position where you're voting for your
own increase while still in office
I think that's a very important
principle and I remember the first time
and I want to say his name in this
chamber because he never sat in it I was
taken to task when I first didn't vote
for the rise by a certain councilor
Melvin
who said it was absolutely abhorrent
that I was getting an increase in my
allowance by the votes of other people
so as I agreed with him for the rest of
the term the Deliverance I would give to
charity and then he didn't have to be
angry so that's what we did so so I take
it that this is incredibly delicate area
I am slightly concerned I have to say
that the independent panel's
recommendations have been what others
might see as copper plated
but I think on balance I will be
supporting this because an independent
panel just looked at it across party
group has also looked into it but I also
agree that it could have been slightly
better than it probably is but it's an
awful lot better than it has been before
so I will be supporting this thank you
in there and I'd like to ask the manager
governance and Civic office to um so
chair we have now got the timing right
as you say and um the legislation
requires us to revisit every four years
so we'll do it in it's in sync now so we
can carry it forward
yeah on Election literature
thank you very much I I can't see any
more hands um councilman would you like
to add anything
yes thank you chair um I sat on the
cross party group so I think it's
probably
um worthwhile saying a few words just in
summary
um
I'm very grateful to councilor Humphries
for reading out that paragraph I was
going to read it out myself but he's he
beat me to it but that I think is a key
issue that it should be an incentive for
service but not a barrier these
allowances unfortunately when I look
around the chamber and I include myself
in that it tends to be you know older
people serving as counselors it would be
great to see a few more younger folk
more women more representative of our
communities and I think the level of
allowances that we're now proposing
um would I think help
people of working age to serve and
remunerate them a bit better
um
the question is you know why have we
departed from the the panel's
recommendations
um and and those recommendations I think
were good but we we have tweaked them a
little I think we haven't gone far from
where they were and perhaps the most key
thing is is this idea of the public
service discount
um the idea that um our service on the
council should have a kind of voluntary
element to it which I totally accept but
they'd put in 40 and we have downgraded
that to 35 and that's the thing that's
really made the difference
I think there's probably two groups of
people who could be uh picking up on
this issue and I take it that it's
totally a sensitive issue the first one
is is is the kind of press in the public
um you know I don't know how many people
are watching this online uh I don't know
how many journalists are watching online
I'm sure our corporate manager in his
previous role could have made quite a
juicy story about uh you know councilors
voting for a you know a big increase in
their allowance
um
I would say to anyone who who takes that
view who wants to make that kind of
story
just go and follow a counselor around
but what we do and and see how much the
commitment is how much time we give it
or maybe speak to a counselor's partner
you get a very good idea from from them
and the second thing I think the second
group who could be affected by this is
the officers uh who might look at this
and say Well they're getting this this
increase in their in their rate uh why
why shouldn't we get a commensurate
increase as well
um but I look at the the overall hourly
rate and compare that with perhaps what
senior officers are earning I I don't
think we are being overpaid for what we
do I do support these recommendations as
amended and I know some in the chamber
will not I understand that totally we
certainly have a free vote on this side
but I'll be voting for it thank you
thank you very much councilor Morley
would you like to add anything
a couple of points
um the first the first point I'd like to
make is when I said that we don't have
enough counselors to run the council
that wasn't quite what I meant
um I wasn't in the cabinet when we did
that when the boundary reorganization
took place but I am given to understand
that the number of counselors were
decreased from 40
to the number that we have now
on the assumption that we were going to
merge with baber and that therefore it
would be the right number of counselors
so
um and the other the other point I'd
just like to remind people thank you so
much to the opposition who have
volunteered to be on more more
committees I really appreciate that but
most I think all of our committees are
politically proportionate and so there
is not that ability to do that so I
think having two sras is
entirely in keeping with the workload
that we all have
so and the and the other thing is around
the
um reduction from 40 to 35 to for the
public service almost all of us
I'm pretty sure all of us have other
relationships with other non
non-paying organizations if you like
with other charitable organizations
whether it's
citizens advice or the mix or the John
peel Center or Oxfam or local Leisure
centers community centers we all have
that already as part of our
it's in our makeup as counselors
we get involved because we want to do
that public service and so I think 35 is
a very reasonable
number to go for so I would encourage
all of you to to vote for this
um the working party considered it his
cross party considered it and these are
what the working party came up with so
thank you all very much
thank you very much I will now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct an electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair those recommendations
technical hitch sorry
yeah
yeah it's now showing in blue for you to
cast your vote for it so apologies for
the delay there
can I surprise can I take your vote
please
I'm going to abstain okay
no
counselor burn are you um would you like
to cast your boat oh no hang on
can't say well and were you having
difficulties as well
um chair that is 19 4 4 against and
seven abstentions so that his character
thank you that's carried
so we'll move on to um item 20 councilor
appointments I refer you to the table
paper
and this is to appoint counselor Harry
Richardson as a non-executive director
of Freeport
um super Advisory Board
and that's Freeport East Limited
could have a proposed around a second
there please councilor Morley yes yes
and councilor flattman this is his
seconder thank you
um
and I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office
please ask a question well I've got
three actually sorry okay
um
uh three questions very quickly
um I think one of them might have been
answered how long is the appointment for
will he be remunerated for I think
probably we've got the answer
and perhaps the most important thing
will he report back regularly to this
Council thank you
who wants to take that is that councilor
Richardson yes I'm I'm happy to take
that
um all those questions in terms of
duration I don't think it does have a
particular time frame in mind but I
think the terms of reference for the
board itself will specify that it has to
be a counselor so if you know I was uh
yes so effectively the deadline is now
up until up until May within thereafter
is is more open-ended shall we say uh
remuneration no it's it's not reunited
at all
um and the third question yes by what
other channels are appropriate thank you
chair
point of clarification will the name of
The Advisory Board have to be changed to
investment Zone advice and supervisory
board
so chairs you can't and we can now cost
your vote it's showing in blue
chair that's 26 for one against and two
abstentions
thank you
notice
there are none so um I will um that's
the next meeting will be on Thursday the
24th of November
um on at 5 30 and I'll close the meeting
at 8 19 p.m thank you